a North American prodigy goes 4jw gonna
pick him off a swell great round from
swag sofa now a 1 on 2 and swag oh my
god one of the region's greatest support
players go down if I chose picked up now
a triple kill he's gonna get sprayed
down an ACK guess the 1 gets the next
one it's a one-on-one and he's gonna get
the third one as well two of na greatest
mine steel oh they're catching them off
guard all of a sudden out of nowhere
I already LC not looking healthy oh how
do they do it
BAM people's people's careers have just
been ended you made a choice and that's
what happens when you make a choice like
that it's all done man CS gos 2015
mattress and scandal is one of the
biggest scandals in the game's history
for of North America's strongest players
were banned overnight cutting their pro
career shorts all for a few measly skins
during a meaningless steve-o Pro match
[Music]
my power was one of North America's best
teams competing with cloud nine for the
top spot in the region
well why power might not have been able
to get it done internationally but it's
pearls saying if you come to Ural and
you're gonna have to deal with with some
Europeans they dominated at home three
maps total for iBUYPOWER they win on
train their roster made up of Braxton
swag Pierce Tyler's could do to Latham
Josh Steele Nissan Sam Dave marine and
Kevin AZ Kate lariviere
well clearly they had a bright future
ahead of them it seems like only a
matter of time before they put na on the
map but it didn't take long for disaster
to strike going live now netcode guides
versus iBUYPOWER
on August 20th 2014 during steve-o
season five my power went up against
netcode guides on de season which was
set to be a pretty uninteresting match
on eSports betting sites csgo lounge 83%
of people had bet on high power and
going in they seemed like the safer bet
of course things weren't that gotta
FAMAS pushed up from CT spawn flash goes
off they know where he is now makes a
shot and Tariq shuts it down netcode
guides beating iBUYPOWER on season
IV paint were destroyed 16 to 4
the loss was unexpected but given that
IBP had just gotten back from ESL one
cologne understandable the fishy part
was that netcode guides needed that win
to make playoffs but high-power were
already locked in they also co-owned
netcode guys hey what's up guys this
dish from echo God's calm but he since
claimed that he had nothing to do with
team operations we sponsor them but like
I never deal with them they like I do
the content on the website and things
like that like that's like completely
separate than what I deal with but the
strange part wasn't that iBUYPOWER lost
it was the way they lost look at this
they're actually doing a strange buy
here they're going for round two
surprise bah I gotta say the entries are
looking a little weak from r-type our
along with the straps I mean they're
just doing very basic things they're
trying to just fully attack these sites
and not really using any smokes or pop
fly
just for the most part to their
advantage and it's very unlike them that
could have been an easy 3k for him hook
take the beat bomb site though he's
gonna try and get the flank off he's
gonna have to right there can they line
up for him what is he doing why did he
hesitate so much
doesn't matter has this easy gets one
gets taken down Hayes was so very low
they lined up perfectly for him but for
some reason he says he wanted tonight
I bet Howard did not go down swing in
fact they just rolled over now the only
way that I my power can commit here is
to a steel was trying to throw a set
smoke to get them into the site they
have to figure that the bomb is over
there and now they know for a fact they
saw both players there this is gonna be
hard 20 seconds left on the board
this is gonna be scheduled and days
versus Hayes Cutler JDM and FNS they
really just gonna wait the time out
right now this is really happening
skadoodle skadoodle why would I don't
understand they miss easy shots crack
jokes and even put steel on the off
instead of their main offers good you
know and it's very weird to see steel
off being over skadoodle I don't know if
schedules not feeling it right now or
what is going on but I by power is
definitely not playing like I buy power
an article by Richard Lewis posted to
the Daily Dot the next day accused the
team of match fixing it's cited
screenshot between denial eSports
players should Sam and an anonymous
friend on Steve it's like you're saying
like I trust you don't say anything to
anybody like did you enjoy the show kind
of like yo this is a guaranteed thing
that's what the vibe is on a live stream
Dave claimed that Shazam was just being
dramatic and Shazam said he was just
bragging about a smart bet and that
Richard Lewis's article was based more
on speculation than fact I mean it's
just Suzanne being Shazam late I don't
know why Sam streets everything like a
conspiracy like I understand why she's
am does this [ __ ] he's always like
starting out drama we got we got
confirmation from iBUYPOWER Dazed &
Shazaam that none of it's true it's all
[ __ ] the article from Richard Lewis
is kind of based off theory and not off
fact for the next few months Steele and
Dave's denied any and all allegations
that they fear that manage did we ever
throw imagine upsets happen get over
yourselves but in November of 2014 they
were kicked off of iBUYPOWER I rep our
work on the upswing starting to
outperform cloud9 internationally
removing the only two players who could
igl seems like a strange thing to do for
a winning team they were replaced by
desi and nitro a move that had some
scratching their heads dazed rejoined
the team in December 2014 before they
joined hiko in January on a huge-ass
construction that team would go on to
bgx gaming allegations at the match
against net code of guides was thrown
still swirled around the scene but for
the most part it seemed like the scandal
was behind them that was until a post on
the ESEA form appeared with evidence
that seemed to say that the match was
fixed the post was made by torqued
player Derek D Bourne borns former
girlfriend Ashley Black Lotus LeBouf who
posted screenshots of would appear to be
texts between herself and devar
according to that account days told D
born and netcode guides co-founder Casey
Foster that IB P were going to throw the
match and that they should change their
bets
d Bourne also appeared to admit that
they were using a friend duck cut fam to
place the bet because he had access to
nine Smurf accounts the community
dismissed the text so Black Lotus took
them to Britain Lewis who verified and
published them Lewis also spoke to csgo
lounge employee Courtney honey Tim
centerpiece who shed a light on cuts
unusual bet after investigation by CSKA
lounge they had found that most of the
big winners on that game
to cut and his steam friends according
to Honeycutt had his nine Smurfs all
placed the maximum bet of 1190 $3.14 he
also said that a couple of the accounts
were made just to bet on that one match
and that cosmetic history showed that he
wasn't one to bet it all on just one
game ten days later valve released a
blog post simply titled integrity and
fair court could Deeb 1kc foster phased
swag AZK seal r.i.p ladies and gentlemen
valve had finally stepped in with a ban
on cud D born kc foster dazed ATK swag
and steel valdon initially state how
long the bands would last but in a
follow-up post stated that they were
permanent not only were they banned from
doll events but they were banned from
alse evo ESEA
Dreamhack face it a league and ASL
events among others their pro careers
were over though there are conflicting
reports regarding skadoodle involvement
with the fix valve didn't find a reason
to ban him during their investigation
then the story breaks at this point time
they're looking at bandana
but the story breaks that you know
they've done some software oh then the
guy comes back with the skins like I've
got the skins now that's the point at
which skadoodle doesn't accept the skins
that's not true by the way
I don't know where that came from but
that is not true at all
I don't know whose source throwing out
on that like Scott just didn't want
anything to do with it from the start
and skadoodle showed some of the
potentials that high power had when he
went on to win a major with cloud nine
and 2018 you're crying stop so what
happened to the rest of the iBUYPOWER
players they're still banned from valve
events but some third-party organizers
have lifted their bans
aside from ECS and eleague dazed either
what congratulations my man your own van
what your unbend steal an ack played
professional overwatch for a bit making
very short runs with splice and team
illiquid if he can jump ship back to CS
in 2017 after those few tournament
organizers decided to unban them azk is
the most the unluckiest human I've ever
met
fight over watch he's getting good he's
a pro in overwatch he's on a team
they're doing that they're not getting
paid well yet because overwatch is still
small all of a sudden he gets unbanned
from one lead and then he decides you
know what I'm gonna quit overwatch to go
back to CS drove he's on a team in
premier mountain dew lead they're
getting no salary and just who's good
enough in salary overwatch League deal
and Dave's also did some analysts work
with ESL and BTS among a few others swag
on the other hand got a streaming
contract with c9 and played with the
team at CS summit one they've all played
on beat here squad since but surely no a
list or would ever sign a player who
can't participate in the major no matter
how good they might be some members of
the community don't agree with thousand
band especially considering there were
no rules regarding match fixing at the
time so the community is still split the
firm events [ __ ] heartbreaking man
these guys have put in for the past year
these guys been planed with the notion
that hopefully at the end of the bat of
the year they'll be unbanned
they'll be able to compete again get
bucks days sorry bro you're the
ringleader you should burn and I'm just
so sad that you [ __ ] brats wagon with
this [ __ ] with you that you took
advantage of a [ __ ] young star that
we that had everything ahead of him and
that he could he could have [ __ ] gone
on to become one of the best North
American players of all time to [ __ ]
dominate worldwide and you've ruined
that so [ __ ] you you need to burn I
don't give a [ __ ] about him and I don't
give a [ __ ] about steel either that guy
he can be the friendliest guy he can be
the biggest troll piece of [ __ ] he wants
on the stream but that guy also can burn
because they [ __ ] knew
so no mercy throw the book at them let
them hang I don't give a [ __ ] valve has
been notoriously stubborn when it comes
to this case valve didn't like listened
to anything and just going going off on
their own will what they won't and that
is really like I don't know if you'd
done the risk but it should be more
talked about while they were zero
tolerance policy for cheaters and
matchmaking slapping them with a
permanent and non-negotiable ban pros
that are caught cheating have only been
given a two-year competitive ban
convicted cheaters can be unbanned but
these guys who threw a virtually
meaningless match are banned forever
I think valve made a bad decision
letting the cheaters come back because
if anything they shall let anyone come
back it seems like regardless of what
the iBUYPOWER guys do to rectify this
issue they're never going to play in a
valve event ever again Timmy what the
man on the phone wants you to do is
something called match fixing don't do
what he says even Richard Lewis the
reporter that broke this story has said
that the punishment doesn't make sense
and I wrestle with it every day and some
days I wake up and I go if I knew it was
gonna be a lifetime ban I wouldn't have
done it and then other days I wake up
and I go you know what it was the right
thing to do because I care about the
community and I want them to know that
the games are genuine whether this is
the end of the story or there's still
more to come valve a sent a very clear
message that match-fixing in csgo will
not be tolerated for young any talents
had their careers cut short and for now
it seems like they won't be coming back
bye bye power we're supposed to headline
a new era of na strength but when cloud
9 finally made that era happen
Boston mostly iBUYPOWER players were
forced to watch from the sidelines
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button